hi this is pressure Locker we start this
game with six empty glasses that are
placed in a row you can number the
glasses from one to six starting from
the left we roll a standard eye and
whatever number we roll we're going to
fill that glass with liquid if we roll
another number we fill that glass with
liquid if we roll a number four a glass
that's already full we're going to drink
that glass so that it becomes empty we
continue playing this game by rolling
the dice and continue filling up glasses
or emptying them as necessary at some
point we might have five glasses that
are full if we roll a number four the
empty glass then we're going to fill
that glass and then we have to drink all
six of the glasses and at this point the
game ends the question for you is
starting from the beginning of the game
what is the average number of rolls
until the game ends give this problem a
try and when you're ready keep watching
the video for the solution the answer is
that it's going to take approximately
eight it's going to take about eighty
three point two rolls for this game to
end let's see why we're going to start
imagining from nearly the end of the
game
imagine you have five full glasses how
many rolls an average is it's going to
take for the game to end at this point
we're going to write a of X for the
rolls needed if we already have x full
glasses so if we have five full glasses
we have a of five is going to be given
by a certain equation there are two
things that can happen when we roll the
dice there's a 1/6 chance we're going to
get the number for the empty glass at
this point the game is going to end so
there's a 1/6 chance that our game is
going to end in one turn however there's
a 5/6 chance we're going to roll a
number for one of the glasses that's
already full at this point we're going
to drink one of the glasses so we end up
in a state of the game that has four
full glasses
so in 5/6 of the cases it's going to
take as one
turn to get to the state of having four
full glasses now how many roses is going
to take when we have four full glasses
we can do a similar equation if we have
four full glasses then there's a 2/6
chance we're going to roll one of the
empty glasses which means it's going to
take as 1 turn to get to the state of
five full glasses there will also be a
four six chance that we're going to roll
a number for one of the glasses that's
full so we're going to drink a glass
which means we'll only have three full
glasses so it's going to take us one
turn to get to the state of three full
glasses well now we have to figure out
what's going to happen if we have three
full glasses we can similarly write an
equation there's a three six chance
we're going to go to the state of having
one four full glasses and there's also
three six chance we're going to go to
the state of having two full glasses
well now we need to figure out what
happens if we have two full glasses and
we can similarly figure out that there's
another equation that describes it in
terms of the states of going to three
full glasses or one full glass now we go
to the state of having one full glass
there's going to be a five six chance
that we roll one of the empty glasses
and we end up with two full glasses or
there's a 1/6 chance that we roll one of
the one glass which is full we drink it
and we go to the state of having zero
full glasses the state of having zero
full glasses is what the game is at the
very beginning at this state of course
there's a certain chance six out of six
chance we're going to roll one of the
empty glasses so it's going to take one
turn to get to the state of having one
full glass so now I'm going to copy over
the equations that we just described in
the following in the previous slides so
we end up with six equations having six
variables ez row to e5
when you have a linear system of n
equations and n variables you can
actually uniquely solve for all of these
variables I'll skip the algebra but you
end up with the with the result that the
expected number of rolls when you have 0
glasses full when the game is beginning
is eighty three point two rolls so it
takes a very very long time for this
game to end
I would not recommend playing this game
will solve for all the other variables
and you can see that even when you have
five full glasses it's going to take
sixty three more roles for the game to
end so although there's a 1/6 chance so
you're going to fill that empty glass
and just finish the game it's actually
very likely that you're going to go back
and you're going to end up in these
cycles of going through many glasses
that are full until you end up finally
filling all the glasses and having the
game end did you figure it out thanks
for watching this video please subscribe
to my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch run on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Hall Walker and if you liked the video
please check out my books there links in
the video description